welcome everybody to this episode of the
into the impossible podcast
i am your lately very fearful host brian
keaton
uh professor of physics at the
university of california san diego and
co-director
of the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
and today's guest couldn't be more
fitting for the grand
themes that sir arthur c clarke laid out
for exploration of the cosmos
and she not only ranks as one of the few
human beings i've ever talked to who's
been in space and flown in space and
even been an artificial satellite of a
kind
much the same kind that arthur c clarke
thought about
but uh but she's also the second guest
who's flown in space on this podcast
the first actually the first was uh dr
yvonne kegel
uh who's a flight surgeon her call sign
is space surgeon
uh she unfortunately i don't think she
ever flew in space but she's a
member of the national uh uh aeronautics
and space administration's astronaut
core she does tremendous work around the
country and the second one was nick
was matt mccall that's you was uh dr
jessica mear while she was on the space
station
back in january uh she spoke with us
she's an alumni
of uc san diego scripps institution of
oceanography
so nicole it's a great pleasure to
welcome you on the into the impossible
podcast
my pleasure to be here i love the title
yes yeah we're going to get into the
title and where it comes from
i have behind me this wonderful image
made by your
your employer nasa your former employer
i guess it is uh
although you're once an astronaut you're
always an astronaut uh and
i was hoping we met through a mutual
friend lawrence balter who
runs the maui flight academy in
beautiful maui
hawaii and i uh he graciously connected
me
uh after only a little bit of begging
for connection to you he connected us
together
and i was hoping to say you know we're
both pilots and we both uh between the
two of us we've both
flown uh you know either a cirrus or up
the space shuttle and you know that
could be my kind
of claim to fame yes between the two of
us we flew
and it reminds me i heard a story once
when wilt chamberlain scored 100 points
back
in the 50s or 60s in a basketball game
the point guard for the team said i'll
always remember this night
as the night that will chamberlain and i
teamed up for 102 points
i feel like i could be like that with
you we teamed up between the two of us
to fly on the space shuttle and uh
and a cirrus um so uh it's a great
pleasure to have you here we're gonna
talk a lot about it you may not know or
maybe you do there's a great connection
between uc san diego
and the astronaut program of course the
first uh the first woman
from the united states to ever go in
space was uh dr sally ride my late
colleague
physics department this has been share's
wonderful biography of her
uh it's called sally ride america's
first woman in space
in addition we had uh we were deeply
connected to
the first uh female space tourist which
was a musha ansari
i don't know if you can see this this is
a book written by my friend uh
julianne guthrie who wrote this book
called how to make a spaceship and
julianne's a friend of the aircraft
clark center
so we have a good connection there um
and then
catherine sullivan is an astronaut who
wrote this book
and uh she has an honorary degree from
the scripps institution of oceania
so we produce a lot of a lot of uh
outstanding astronauts
and uh i'm very pleased to to welcome
you at least
you could be an honorary senior well
thanks i'll take it i'll take it my
husband went to
scripps so i kind of have oh he did all
right perfect
yeah yeah and he's he's probably done
some work with you even if indirectly
through the
the arthur c clarke um institute so oh
that's wonderful yeah it is a small
world and you know catherine just
what was it two days ago now yesterday
or two days ago went to the deepest part
of the ocean
too did you see that oh i didn't hear
about that yeah
yep what what is that like 35 000 feet
yeah what is that mariana's train
yeah yep she just did that a couple days
ago so
where else to go and i want to get into
that where do you go from there you know
sort of
what do you what do you get the woman
who has everything and has done
everything so we're going to get into
that
in the in the future of this of this
podcast don't don't you worry
i want to talk a little bit uh first
just about the actual
um the actual mission that you have i
see you having
a mission in life that is unquenchable
and i want to get into not only what
that mission is but do that first
but also what drives you to do that and
where you got this
the set of integrity work ethic what
have you to accomplish everything that
you have done and
we're going to get into your art and
space and your first project space for
your space for art project and actually
the art that you did while you were on
the space station so let us turn now i'm
going to go to your a powerpoint
presentation that you prepared i'm going
to start this
up and i'm going to go to share my
screen
and you tell me if you can see that
nicole i can see that
yeah awesome yeah okay so you'll tell me
what we're looking at and then tell me
when i should push uh to go ahead
okay and this so this presentation is
the same this is the one that we used
with
uh lawrence for the maui flight academy
so there's a little bit of a flight
twist on it but
i think it works for just um i don't
know
explaining the experience in space too
and regardless of whom i'm present
presenting to this is my first slide
always
because this one picture reminds me
what it was like to be in space
i think when i look at it it's really
beautiful and i can tell you you look
out the window of a spaceship
and it is gorgeous um and while it looks
like this little silhouetted version
of the space shuttle atlantis is just
hanging there still
you know we know you know that that's
that we're actually traveling at about
17
500 miles an hour about five miles a
second around the planet which means we
lap the planet once every 90 minutes or
so and
and that means every 45 minutes or so we
get one of these
stunning sunrises or sunsets out the
window and
so that had to be in the picture of what
reminded me of space i know that i'm
inside that little space shuttle with
my um crew that were coming home after a
successful mission
this was the sts-129 crew who picked me
up after three months in space
and i also know that my friend jeff
williams is still on the space station
and he took this really awesome picture
for us uh
it's nice to have the memory this way
and is this does this image do justice
to the colors and the hues and
sort of the appearances that you can see
only from space
you know i don't and i say this because
i don't think any
picture really ever does that for us
because
um you know in one way or another when
we have the chance to see
something and i'm sure well i hope you
feel the same way you're flying in an
airplane you're driving down a beautiful
countryside country road and you take a
picture of it there's more than what you
see
right there's kind of like what you're
feeling as you're experiencing it too
and i don't think the pictures actually
do that um
this this photo too was taken back in
2009 so the cameras weren't
quite as good as they are they are right
now but i don't
i don't know that i've ever seen one
that um captures it quite
like just kind of the vibrance the
iridescence kind of translucent that i
remember seeing when i looked at it
myself i
i haven't seen that yet in a picture wow
so the next slide i have is uh of a
uh of a biplane this looks like
it looks like a slightly older picture
of you but uh walk us through this one
well that's my dad in the back cockpit
and i am
in the front cockpit at that point too
little
to see over the top of it but my dad
would make the
you know moves that allowed me to get
kind of the upside down view of
um the world below me very thankful for
you know since i was a young child
having kind of that perspective
presented to me where you know you
separate from the planet in some way and
see things
all new and i show this picture really
because it reminds me that
a little to the the topic that we'll
discuss which is
you know i am so thankful to have had
parents that shared what they loved with
me
and my my sisters i mean honestly i
think i discovered
things that i love like flying or
wanting to know how things fly and
things that i maybe wasn't so excited
about just by what they
they were willing to share with us and
um the flying thing definitely got into
my blood i wanted to know how things fly
i
discovered that if you want to know how
airplanes fly why would you not want to
know how rocket ships fly
and you know that led me down the path
of studying aeronautical engineering
and you know ultimately having a job as
a
nasa engineer at the kennedy space
center and i think our next slide might
be that
yep and really i mean really really
fortunate
to work at kennedy space center so this
was the
late 80s when we were starting to get
back to flight after
you know after the challenger accident
and that's me where you got the cursor
the purple shirt there in the center big
hair
you know the 80s we had big hair and i i
mean i love this shot because
it's you know first of all we're um
we're out on the runway
with the hardware you know i mean that
was the best thing about working
at ksc was i mean you know every job you
end up having a bad day every now and
then
you know but when you could walk down
into a hangar and touch a space shuttle
i mean that was
just turned it around you know and not
to not to even
i mean the people that i got to work
with there um
all of them and the kind of people you
want to work with that are passionate
about what they're doing
i mean all these folks in this picture
believe that the care and feeding of
those spacecraft were their
responsibility
and you know when i
eventually got to fly in one of them or
two of them it was like
you know you're thankful that that's the
kind of people that are working
that are working although i imagine you
know once somebody asked me you know and
i was going through
you know flight training in a cessna 152
as t-shirt as a shirt i'm wearing
commemorates that
uh fateful craft that i love so much yet
i never thought of well let me go down
and see how they're doing the
maintenance on this
like i'd be so scared to like yeah do it
i did go down believe me but um was it
not a little bit nerve-wracking we're
gonna get into like the notion of fear
and overcoming fear and all its
dimensions that you encounter later on
uh but um it just always struck me as
wow do you really wanna be
in a this thing is basically a sculpture
right i mean i remember an astronaut
came to my
uh first grade class in the 80s and
showed us tiles of the space shuttle
she heated it up with a blow torch and
then we could touch it and it made this
huge impression on me in two ways one
this incredible technology maybe i could
be an astronaut
um and uh but maybe maybe not as the
case turned out to be but also this was
like a sculpture i mean this thing was
individually fitted hand crafted hand
placed uh
did you did you have concerns about that
i mean knowing so much about it does it
make you a little bit more trepidacious
um i think it made me feel better
actually to know about
it to have seen the way these perk
people worked as they were placing
each one of those tiles i mean really
the care that they took with it
and i mean i was in all of it honestly
to watch the
you know not just the skill but i mean
the real care that went into it
and it was so cool i don't think i
included the picture but one of my very
favorite pictures
of launch day was you know we would get
in the astro van the silver van and
right out to the launch pad
and um i remember watching that as an
employee watching the astronauts go by
in the van and waving to them and you
know that kind of thing
and on that day um we're riding out in
the van i
specifically sat as close to the the
door as i could
because we would always stop right by
the launch control center and our
managers would get out to go into the
control center and then we would head
off
you know the astronauts would head off
on their way to the launch pad
and when we did that i just peeked my
head out the window
out the door and like wave
and somebody got a picture of that and
it was all this like whole group of
people
that i mean that i had stood with before
that i had worked with before that were
like waving me on now you know to go out
to the pad and
just i i think it feels good to know
that people
care about what they're doing you know
right they're such professionals they're
so passionate we'll skip through this
although it's wonderful this is kind of
the flight nerd
uh and me that can't resist that we're
talking about the t38s and the gulf
stream but yeah
um i wanna and the here's your astronaut
i wanna go forward to the actual uh
flight so that we can cover everything
so much to talk about with you
so here's this uh giant tractor this
giant
four-wheel drive or whatever that is uh
taking this is the this is discovery
right this is taking
down a couple miles is that the launch
pad that you're on in the background
that's the launch pad right out there
all lit up
i mean i love this picture so this my
second flight was the final flight of
the space shuttle discovery
and so this was the last time that the
vehicle rolled out of that ginormous
vehicle assembly building on the crawler
mobile transporter here
and made its way like what at like
almost a mile an hour
out to the launch pad right and i love
it because you know the kind of the
artist in me looks at this and says oh
my gosh this is just so gorgeous the
colors
you know all of it and then i look at it
and i think
everywhere you look in this picture
there's like a level of complexity
that's kind of mind-boggling you know
whether it's the
tread on the crawler or like the tip of
the orange fuel tank or
i mean anything pick it that the launch
pad in
the distance you know the way they had
to design that crawler way with these
special rocks from some riverbed in
arkansas or something i don't know
i mean it's incredible and there is
there's like this this level of
engineering and just the way those rocks
would crush
and move as the vehicle you know rolled
along out to the launch pad i just think
it's this
beautiful image of what we can do you
know when we decide to do it
yeah and correct me if i'm wrong but um
but this may have been the last
flight of uh of a vehicle on the side of
a
of its propulsion system right the new
uh dragon etc those are all
back on the top of rockets going back to
the apollo era i think the shuttle was
was the last vehicle
really in planning stages to ride on the
side so to speak
yeah i think so even sierra nevada
that's doing kind of the smaller winged
you know lifting body version they're
going to be at the top of an atlas i
think so yeah
yeah so it's it's a little different i
mean i love
this vehicle not just because i worked
on it not just how i flew on it but i
think there's a legacy that it's going
to have
yeah that we won't see for a long time
and i mean it was kind of it was
designed by committee
right you know usually that doesn't work
out all that well
right and look at the elephants right
yeah but i mean this thing you know it
did
cargo well it did deployments well it
did science well it did
taken humans well for the most part
telescope right yeah
servicing that television yeah and
discovery was the vehicle for that yeah
so that's right
yeah so here you are inside uh doing a
simulation and
we'll talk through this um a little bit
more quickly this is your son
yeah that you're so tender to see this
and
imagining what you must be thinking yeah
eventually you're going to go to space
and you're such a good mom i can tell
from all the background that i've done
uh just thinking about leaving any one
of my kids behind i
can't i can't imagine it you you're
you're you must have this this special
gift to
to really know what's great for him is
also that his seeing his mother
do the impossible well it's it's i it is
a bit of a difficult thing though too
you know i mean you can see him he's
little i mean
and now he's sitting across from me he's
almost 18 but
i mean he was seven when i flew the
first time and
so it was really important to me and my
husband that we get him out to all these
things that you see in these pictures
you know we kind of do what my
parents did for me shared what they
loved with me but
even more than that it was important to
us that he feel like he was part of my
crew that he know the people that he
know the work i was doing
and you know so he could understand that
and be comfortable with it and
i think he did we could ask him
where is he turn the camera on well yeah
yeah
uh maybe we will because later later
we'll i want to discuss those
aspects of fear and i've heard i've
heard you say you know it wasn't so much
what would happen to you but what might
happen to him and i'd love to
talk about this as a father a parent to
another parent
what does that like because you know i
set off for a business trip in a 737
and i get nervous i don't think it
matters where you go and on what vehicle
you're on
i think
yeah the stakes change right once you
once you become a a guardian of a
of a little tiny human being a precious
soul so here you are
this is the moment of truth uh this is
just phenomenal
so this is discovery on its last voyage
into the heavens
uh what was this was your sec this is
your second flight
this actually this was at night so this
must have been the first one because
that was like
like a minute before midnight on uh 128
and then
beautiful clear blue sky for 133 during
the day yeah
were you just like at that moment i was
thinking and watching the spacex flight
recently you know like
they just want to get it off the ground
and have been scrubbed like is that the
way you were you were just like we gotta
go no matter what get their itis
so to speak well i think i mean
to some degree but i think you know when
you when you take off on
your airplane if there's if somebody
calls you and tells you
they see something wrong with your plane
or you discover you don't want to roll
down the runway
all right right so the same thing is
true when you're strapped into
a a rocket ship and um
yeah you want to go though you don't
believe you're going to go though until
it gets down into that kind of iconic
109.8 thing
yeah um and then you're thinking oh holy
moly and then before you know it you've
like been blasted off this launch pad
in a way that is just like holy moly was
i ever on a launch pad kind of thing
and shaken and and then here you go to
your uh your flying hotel the size of
the football field or so
it's not so gorgeous this is a
masterpiece this
is i mean there's no better example of
living off the grid than this spaceship
and um absolutely from
the international partnership standpoint
from the technology standpoint
of how it's built and run to the science
of it i mean we
we've built this this mechanical system
in space to mimic what earth does for us
naturally
so that we can go up there live work and
do
all of this work that's really
ultimately about improving life on earth
yeah including science including basic
fundamental science research
yeah uh so i believe this is this is you
at the end of the canada arm right
it is it's me at the end of the arm um
i think we were talking you know about
kind of the iso
that's the most isolated i've ever been
i'll tell you about it that ryden you
know the farthest from
the planet i guess but and and yet
feeling it's kind of like
i i'm feeling now you know we're in our
homes or we're
you know getting out very rarely to
places and there's this isolation that
at the same time i'm able to do this
with you and be connected
and have that same experience with my
family or friends to keep track of them
and
um kind of like it was up there too yeah
i mean i've heard it described as a
unique combination that you sort of have
agoraphobia and acrophobia all at once
you're like
totally isolated you turn one direction
and there's nothing
you know until uh way beyond alpha
centauri and
they look the other way and you're like
wow i am 200 miles above the earth's
surface
and i'm a natural uh you know a human
maid your mother made you
a satellite floating around the earth uh
those emotions
and yet you're like the most technical
you look like iron woman you know with
all these tools
and the utility pack and everything um
so awesome
uh so is there a letdown after you after
you do this i mean
so few i mean how many people has walked
in space i mean it's
it's a number that's under a couple
hundred it's gotta be yeah
yeah it is uh it is i mean i was the
tenth woman
to do so i think at that point i don't
know how many people there were but yeah
it's i don't think it's a letdown um i
wish i could have done it done another
one so i actually could have gotten the
memory into my brain
it's so i mean everything about space
flight is surreal but this is probably
the surrealist
of you know the experience to be in your
own little personal spaceship crawling
around the outside of your bigger one
and
very diligent and deliberate and i think
you're
you're occupying so much of your brain
with just doing what you need to do
out there that um it doesn't
you know i've i have certain memories of
it again i'm thankful for pictures like
this
because um yeah and every astronaut has
their own stripes this is their
identifier
so yeah so i think danny who was my
partner out
there he had white like a white stripes
and i had red stripes just so they can
identify who you are
because you know if you're turned around
nobody's going to know who you are right
yeah exactly
you can't see through the face shield or
yeah right yeah
and then did you did you take any time
to just like i'm going to turn around
because i'm
never going to be here i might not ever
be here again and just like take it all
in or you're just so busy
checklist after checklist report after
report
how was it yeah you do take the time
well like you know like riding on the
end of that arm definitely you know i
had 25 minutes of going from the end of
the station down to the
payload bay of the space shuttle and you
know there's not a whole lot you can do
except for hold on to that box and
you know make sure your teammates are
still there and you're comfortable but i
mean i remember like watching the
station move out of my view the earth
moved below me and then the space
shuttle pop up and
it's like i didn't even feel like i was
moving it's so cool
and there you are out the window there
that's a
stunning picture there i love that
picture yeah the space shuttle is a
has like a personality first of all it
looks like snoopy
and many of us grew up uh you know just
adoring it
and having such fun memories now you are
in the cupola right on the space station
so what's that like we interviewed
jessica muir and she just reported this
is her favorite place
it is everybody's favorite place i can
guarantee you that
um you know on my first flight the
cupola wasn't there on my second flight
it was
and on my second flight um mike barrett
was on our crew
on 133 and two the two of us had been on
station together without the cupola
and we came through the hatch of the
shuttle onto the station together and it
was kind of like that side glance and
then pushing each other out of the way
trying to
like fly as fast as we could to get and
see that view it is
just this bay window like horizon to
horizon view
of the planet you know you're looking at
the planet
i mean there's no denying it it is yeah
this is where people are when they're
not
working yeah it seems like one you know
nasa is not known for its you know
touchy-feely side you know connecting
uh although thanks to the work of
yourself and and
like-minded people you know it's
becoming more attuned to
what really makes us human beings and
part of that
is this uh thirst for beauty and for
the spiritual if you will connection to
the planet to the to the universe and i
think you know
it's interesting that nasa did this uh
you know for the benefit of the
astronauts but actually in benefiting
the astronauts i think it benefits the
planet as a whole
yeah and i'd like to think that they did
it for the benefit of the astronauts
honestly i think you see those little
screens down in the bottom right corner
yeah those are little computer monitors
and displays
for flying the the canada arm right
okay so that's our workstation for
flying the kit i honestly think you know
and you would appreciate this i think
you know this is an earth-facing
observatory too you know workspace we
need one on the top of the space station
that faces out to deep space you know
there's we do as much work on
that side of the station when we're
outside crawling around it as we do the
earth-facing and i mean
get it really dark inside of there and
start looking i mean it would be
incredible incredible put a couple
telescopes there well
if there's anyone you need me to talk to
here's a view of florida uh your your
home state currently you can see
uh the everglades and uh lake okeechobee
it's been a while since i've been to
florida it's amazing you go from the
flattest
most boring in terms of topography uh
state and that's where we launch from
and then we go into like yeah i think
the highest part of florida is a garbage
dump
i love florida my uh my relatives all
live there
i love the east coast in those clear
blue waters but it must be special when
you come over your hometown and you're
uh where you live and see it from this
perspective and
and as you always point out this thin
blue line that's the atmosphere i mean
the atmosphere is exponential
yeah it's so thin you know the real thin
blue line
talk talk to us about what images like
this mean to you and how they might have
inspired this project we'll get to that
next
well i'll tell you this um you know i
look
at pictures like this and i mean when i
got to space i wanted to see florida you
know i wanted to look out the window see
what i consider to be my home you know
we're always looking for something
familiar when we go to new places right
so i wanted to see that through the
window
if i knew florida was gonna be below me
i
was you know fly into the window to see
it and it was
interesting how quickly and you know
i i think probably your other astronaut
guest jessica i'm guessing would have
said something similar is how
this place that i considered a home home
like evolves very quickly into this like
special place
on the planet that's our home right and
you start
thinking that way you start
understanding the interconnectivity of
it all
um you start appreciating this veil
this thin blue veil that protects us all
and i started you know like comparing
that to the thin metal hall
of my space station and you know how
those two things are keeping all the
good stuff in so that we can survive
and you know and how we wanna like on
the station i mean my gosh
every day we are acutely aware
of how much co2 is in our atmosphere or
the integrity of our hall how much clean
water there is all these things that we
know
we are like necessarily dependent on and
to survive
and we should be doing that same thing
down here i mean it's just this
you know i know it's matter of scale
number multiple scales of six people
versus what the seven point whatever
billion you were mentioning
earlier but i mean it's true it's just
gotta be crewmates so when i uh i'll
take
a stop for one second just to go over
here to my notes i want to read my notes
from
a famous uh astronaut edgar mitchell
who's a popular astronaut he
he has this famous statement you develop
as an astronaut you develop an
instant global consciousness a people
orientation
an intense dissatisfaction with the
state of the world and a compulsion to
do something about it
from out there on the moon the
international politics look
so petty you want to grab a politician
by the scruff of the neck and drag him a
quarter million miles out and say look
at that you son of a blank
uh it's a pg-13 show so i want to keep
it clean uh but
when you when you hear that um well
first of all
do you agree i mean that was back then
that was when politics was very
polarized nowadays we get along so well
no there's no polarization right
right so i'm not sure where you're
living
in southern california isn't it like
that
of course i'm joking it's getting you
know my favorite thing to do is to bring
up there's a famous article in
the magazine i think it's a science
magazine from uh
from way back when it says you know the
recent elections politics have been so
divisive and
we've never been so divided in our in
our history and i showed it after the
2016 election
that's a talk i gave at the hayden
planetarium and everyone's like laughing
like oh that was written a couple days
ago
it was written 1972 and it was about
like the 72 election which
i'm sure it was potential but what do
you think about this like
first of all um would you do that do you
think i mean we had paul john glenn went
to space obviously he'd already been in
space
um do you think it's really necessary i
mean if it really requires that we take
a politician to space
is that really you know going to happen
it shouldn't right
i don't i i really my i hold hope that
it doesn't require us flying
you know multiple politicians up to butt
heads
and float in front of a window to prove
to them
that this is a planet that we live on
that we're all interconnected that this
is
you know our home um and personally i i
don't believe you have to go to space to
get that
feeling edgar had that he spoke to you
know you don't have to go to the moon to
see earth this way to to
i i mean i look around me now um
i think more since being you know in my
own home and i've been paralleling it
quite a bit to
you know what i experienced in space as
this way to appreciate a whole new
perspective of something
you know to look out in my backyard and
see things that i
i thought i really knew was familiar
with and like reacquaint myself with
them
and i think we have that opportunity all
the time there is awe
and wonder surrounding us i mean i go
out now like to speak to
kind of your world um this idea of
living on a planet
i mean i go outside now and it's usually
when there's a space station pass and
i'm looking for my friends passing over
and i try to get my neighbors you know
hey you need this app on your phone so
you can
see oh you didn't know there was a space
station well you know
which everyone should know and but i
try really hard and i think it's kind of
a almost a meditative kind of thing
is to make a connection with earth like
feel my feet
like as like part of earth like down
into
like into earth in some way and then
look up
and just be in awe i mean to know that
we're on this place so
perfectly situated a little closer a
little further from the sun not so good
for us
and to know that you know this is i mean
this is our home i don't think you have
to go to space to feel that
and every astronaut i know wants to
share the experience in
in whatever way they can to you know
because
i think we we should be sharing the
experience i i mean i i'm thankful to
talk to you and i don't know if you can
tell i get excited about this stuff
but it's more than just oh i saw the
earth from space it's so beautiful
it's like okay now you need to recognize
who and where we all are together in
space
right and i want you to be thinking
about the fact that we live on a planet
we're all earthlings thin blue line kind
of thing
and figure out what action you need to
take exactly
exactly and there's so much talk about
this idea and i've heard it before
and um and just looking at your projects
and what you do you mentioned this word
before like how do you scale something
and i think you know it's so interesting
to to see this new project that you
have embarked on at least since retiring
from the active astronaut core
but still being an ambassador both for
space uh worldwide and also for nasa
talk to us about the space for art
project and how we can get involved
how did it come about what's this origin
story here i'll play it i think there's
yeah you can play it it's um so um
so when i retired from nasa you know i
had the chance there's not a picture in
here i don't think but i had the chance
to paint myself
in space i painted with watercolors did
this painting of a
you know beautiful place that i'd seen
on earth and
my goal when i retired was to use art my
own art as a way
to communicate share the space flight
experience
and and like those neighbors that might
not know about the space station
to um encourage them to learn about what
we're doing in space that's all about
improving life on earth and as a as a
result of that i got introduced to a
gentleman
named ian scion who um an artist and he
was the founder and director of the
art and medicine program at md anderson
their pediatric cancer center
and he always did projects where he
would take the kids art and build them
into some
you know bigger larger scale thing where
their artwork was coming together with
the other kids
and he wanted to do something with space
and actually he wanted to go to space
and be the artist in residence on the
space station
yeah and i told him stand in line dude
because it's an expensive gig yeah
that's not happening yet so we decided
on spacesuits there's another one like
right here behind me
um that it's our latest project where we
had kids from
over 45 countries involved in hospitals
and refugee
centers and and really it's space-themed
art therapy
and i'll tell you you know you get in a
room with these kids who
are going through on and as a father
you'll get this
i mean i think any human being gets this
that these kids are going through
what you hope is the worst thing they
ever have to deal with in their entire
lives
you know and if you can come in there
and encourage them
to through art and space like think
about their own futures they start
talking to you about their own future
and what they see
and all these things and they get pretty
philosophical too
i mean in the grand scheme of space
stuff as well i mean i had this one
little girl talk to me
about i mean she was if she was eight
she was that was old
you know and she's painting and we're
talking and she's like oh you know miss
nicole um
going to space and being an astronaut
that must be a lot like what it what i'm
going through here in the hospital
and i'm like how in the world you know
can this child
be equating what i hope is the worst
thing she ever has to go through
to something you know that i dreamed
about that i was blessed to get to do
and i just let her keep talking
and she says yeah you know you don't get
to see your mommy and daddy
and your friends the same way and you
know you have to eat all different kinds
of food and they're doing all different
kinds of tests on you
and i think you have this stuff this
radiation that you have to deal with i
mean all these things
i'm thinking holy moly how did she
figure that out
and it made me realize that you know as
we start as human beings thinking about
traveling further away from our planet
to the point where we don't have that
connection anymore that
view of earth out the window that really
helps us relate to who and where
where we've known forever we're gonna
need things like this we're gonna need
you know
to be able to do art or play music on
the ipad or have the holodeck or
whatever you know whatever it is
to to help maintain that kind of
you know psychological connection
um i want to show some of them some of
the art that you've done
while in space i think it's the first of
its kind right so i'm showing can you
see on
can you see your own work okay yeah so
this is called
the wave this original watercolor on
paper uh
oh not for sale i was gonna see i like
all my guests to give away like a little
patch or something i don't think we can
afford this
that one no the original is not for sale
there are some prints
of that um and uh
that's the only painting i did in space
um i just got the original back from
smithsonian it was on display at air and
space museum but they're going through a
major
uh remodel and they didn't want to
be responsible so
i got that back now but i'll tell you
you know things like this and what we
talked about earlier it's really it's
like putting the human in human space
flight right
here you know really kind of finding an
emotional connection to it it was very
it's one of my very
favorite memories of being in space it's
so wonderful
yeah before we started talking you said
that this image behind me which is
from the nasa wmap satellites image of
the cosmic microwave background
radiation which is the
branch of cosmology that i study and
research and
love to talk about as much as you'd love
to talk about um there's some connection
that you have to this particular image
and maybe it's his artistic
quality it is gorgeous don't you think i
mean i
really i mean if we have to i just love
it when something like this
represents the science of what's going
on you know in the world in the universe
too
you know it's kind of like hubble images
to me you know we false color them so
the scientists can understand which
gases are in it or you know how far is
it that kind of thing and yet it
produces this really beautiful
picture for the rest of us um you know
kind of says how that
something creatively presented or
visually presented is
um in some ways better than the ones and
zeros
um but this picture the one the one
thing i think i shared with you is that
we use this for our next project where i
we invite we're inviting
kids from all over the world you know
we're all in isolation now to
participate in our next project so if
they check out the space for art
foundation page
um they can see how to participate but
um
this was the inspiration for that and
then also i look at this
and this is like this very vivid
reminder to me
of um i don't know it's probably 10
years old
sitting on my bedroom floor with a
national geographic magazine that was
about space
and you know the picture like posters
they would always have and they still do
in the magazine that you pull out i mean
i'd always go searching for that
and it was um i don't know if it was
known universe
observable universe but it was very much
like this picture
and you know like just like you do
you're like oh and they they told you
here's where we are you know
like you are here point you always look
for that first and you start expanding
out and i remember
that time thinking wow this is so cool
you know and then i got to the edge of
the oval or whatever that shape is
yeah and i encountered the white stuff
and i was like wow what is that is that
the unobservable universe
is that the unknown universe is that
heaven
i mean i really i was like is that
heaven is that
what is that you know and then i started
looking
to the sides and the white of the poster
ended and my carpet
on my bedroom floor started and then it
rolls up the window to
look out the window and i'm like what in
the world
that has baffled me to this day
and i think it's okay you know i think
it's one of those things that's okay
we keep learning more and more we keep
sharing this story through something
this this kind of image and it's okay
for us not to know
at all yeah that's a beautiful way to
put it and
yeah einstein supposedly was asked once
um
you know he said uh i don't know if i
can do what you do you know i have so
many so much trouble with math
and he said don't tell me about your
problems with math i have my own
and uh just as you were saying you know
you don't really understand that well
believe me there's a lot that we don't
as professional cosmologists we don't
understand either
um i know your time is so valuable so
limited so i want to get to a couple of
questions
okay i ask all my guests but before i do
that
um because i how often do i get to talk
to a superhero
i want to talk to you you can just talk
to me anytime you know
okay great well i might be careful i
might take you up on that with uh you
know 3 a.m when i'm feeding one of the
kids
um so i want to ask this question uh
because it pertains i think
uh to me and many people like me you
know in academia
there's a tremendous amount of rejection
of fear
of what's so-called imposter syndrome
and i wonder you know
do you astronauts do you specifically
how have you had to deal with that i
mean you literally i mean yes we can
talk about it now
but you know we lost two shuttles in
various uh configurations those are yeah
i asked my wife
you know is it okay if the kids watch
the spacex unless she's like i don't
know you know i remember when i was a
little girl and i saw the challenger
um and i remember that it's like one of
my one of my most prominent memories
how did you knew that when you did that
and yet you did it anyway
how did you overcome what must have been
a naturally you know for a normal person
would be almost paralytic
in a sense how do you how do you handle
fear uh specifically you nicole
do you have tools or tricks or habits or
tactics how can
how can our listeners you know approach
the fear that they might have in their
life from imposter syndrome to fear of
missing out etc
i think it's a i mean i think in the
simplest way it's just
knowledge right you know to the best of
our ability
knowing what we can know about something
and that's why that picture that you
know that picture standing on the runway
with
um endeavor i think is so meaningful to
me
is that you know in in as much as was
humanly possible i know those people
were doing
everything they could to make sure that
that spacecraft would be as safe as it
could
for me to fly on right i knew through
what i'd seen
of my management um that
that they were working that same way you
know to try and ensure
i mean we we we delayed like five or six
times
on my first flight because of things
that just weren't
weren't or didn't feel right to the
people that were responsible for them
and you know i think we've really
evolved very nicely to
um within that whole hierarchy that
whole structure within nasa
and the human space flight management
that people
can say and call halt
when when um it doesn't make sense to
them
um and then for me personally it's like
i need to know those people even if i
hadn't worked at kennedy space center i
think it would have been
i would have been out there wanting to
meet them wanting to know them
to get some of that warm fuzzy uh
you know about it that comfort in my own
gut because of it um
and the knowledge of the systems myself
and you know through all the training we
do
i mean 99.9 of the training we're doing
is about all the stuff that can go wrong
you know it's rare to get in a simulator
and have a nominal day you know
take off and land in the way that you
planned or something's wrong
yeah and and so there's this big you
know this big
like deliberate effort to learn how to
work with your team with your crew
and i was so pleased i mean because
stuff never goes the way you plan even
if it's not catastrophic it's never
going to go
like you plan and um in one way or
another you're going to have to rally
like you did in those simulators
and i was so i was proud and pleased to
see
you know at three o'clock in the morning
when the alarm would the class and
clamoring on the space station that we
all
you know calmly floated out of our sleep
stations
everybody went and did what they were
supposed to do we accounted for everyone
and as much as humanly possible we took
care of it yeah
i mean that's the most you can do and um
i think it's just the knowledge kind of
having some underlying knowledge
of it and yeah wonderful but i'll just
tell you
yeah i'll go ahead i'm going to tell you
though you know from a fear standpoint
because we did we
we discussed this a little bit before um
and
in our other call was like um
i was never afraid for myself i honestly
was never afraid for myself
i was afraid or anxious about my family
watching me launch right that's a lot
more difficult thing to do it was a lot
more difficult for me to watch bob and
doug
launch on that spacex vehicle the other
day than it would have been for me to go
strap into it myself
really and truly so i was afraid for how
my family was feeling and then when i
got to space
i was like like my fear was that you
know
something would happen to my son and i
wouldn't be able to be there that
i mean that's the kind of thing and i
feel that same way when i'm on a trip
to you know anywhere
you mentioned one thing you know a few a
few moments back
as regards you know leadership and the
team and management
and the confidence that you have i want
to read a quote that i heard from you
and also talk about just the concept of
leadership that you
have encountered and exemplified in your
life uh i don't
believe i've ever known someone who's a
good leader who hasn't failed
at least once in his or her life and i
also don't know somebody who's a good
leader
who hasn't been a good follower so to
speak and uh their quote i'm thinking
about that
that i heard you uh it's kind of your
your talisman or your
your guru once said to you here's how we
can
not why we can't what does that mean
that plays to you
oh my gosh it mean it's such a hopeful
phrase
isn't it it's such a like deliberately
positive we will find a solution to this
um
phrase and i mean when that was jay
honeycutt who
like helped the apollo program happen
was the
center director at kennedy space center
um
for years was you know head of the
shuttle program there when i first met
him and
i mean he laid that down on us as young
engineers right off the bat
and that's how he wanted us to work was
with this idea that we can make things
happen
we don't we don't you know we don't need
to be burdening ourselves with all the
reasons why we can't do something
we need to be finding solutions and for
me it's like i try to share it with my
son i'm like dude i want you to come to
me with
a proposed solution not telling me why
we can't you know it's
just help us to do that and i think it's
just such
a great way to live your life in general
with this idea that you will be able to
make something happen
and yeah yeah i yeah i i don't know
wonderful
yeah i think that's wonderful i mean i
always say it's fine to have problems
everybody has problems it's good to have
problems because they point out
inconsistencies or inadequacies of the
standard models that we
go around whether it's the universe or a
big organization
um so i really like that phrase will now
replace failure is not an
option next outstanding mission uh
mission controllers
so the last few minutes i know you gotta
run are
uh dedicated to the final questions that
i ask all my guests and i'm
curious to hear what your responses will
be
so the first one is going to take us
into the future and it involves what's
called an ethical will
not a material will which is you know
where you get this money
et cetera but where do you give your
ethical
values your wisdom and the accumulated
lessons that you had
to articulate them to a future
generation maybe not only
restricted to your own children but to
kind of ideological children as well
wow um yeah that's a really interesting
question
i think you know and reflecting on how i
kind of maybe switched around in my own
ideas of
things i could do you know when i was
young and as i was
getting older um i don't know i mean i
want and i'm looking at my son i want
him
to appreciate the awesomeness
you know that he brings to the world and
to share that
you know really by i think living like
somebody he would want to fall in love
with
you know the kind of person that he
would fall in love with and
to embrace empathy and compassion
um to always be
on we talked about this early like on
the lookout for the on wonder that
surrounds him
as well and you know and and if i ever
have the chance to
share any words of wisdom it's going to
be those three lessons from space
you know we live on a planet where
earthlings only border that matters is
that thin blue line and that we all need
to be living like crew not passengers
that's phenomenal so the next question
takes us
also into the future uh but this time
much much deeper into the future
and this involves uh sort of a relative
uh
derivative aspect of one of our namesake
arthur c
clarke's uh famous scenes in the movie
2001 a space odyssey
all these monoliths these mysterious
objects i'm saying are machines
that are put there by some unseen alien
civilization
perhaps as a warning or as a time
capsule of a sort
what would nicole scott put in her time
capsule and one that has to last for a
billion years
wow i could be material it could be it
could be you know some
some something verbal or written rather
yeah i think it would be
a picture of earth
because you know at that point i think
we've probably expanded ourselves out
into
you know um the universe in one way or
another i hope the
a lot of that sci-fi becomes psy fact
you know that allows us to do that
um and i think as far as we know i mean
maybe you can tell me different but as
far as we know this is
our place of origin this is the place
where regardless of how we spread
ourselves where we
started and i think we just always need
to
connect with that in some way yeah
that's true i actually had
andrew ian who's the widow of the late
great carl sagan
and she and carl of course put on the
voyager
uh spacecraft these plaques that encoded
both sounds of earth uh you know images
that could be decoded of earth
uh uh where to find the earth
relative to a couple of dozen pulsars
that hopefully would still be around
to decode it um yeah so it was quite
wonderful and also on that she actually
recorded her brain waves
and they were recorded around the time
she fell in love with carl so it's quite
lovely
to think about the humanity and these
objects are now uh one percent of a
light year away from earth
so a couple hundred more years they will
be
reached distant uh distant civilizations
perhaps
a couple of thousand more here last
question involves uh the opposite
direction now we're going to go back
okay
and arthur c clarke said uh the third
law
his so-called third law was that the
only way of discovering the limits of
the possible
is to venture a little bit past them
into the impossible and that's actually
the name of this podcast
so i want to ask you a final question
what mysterious aspect
of life you know perplexed you maybe
seemed impossible to overcome as a 20
year old as a 30 year old like some of
our audience
but now uh seems like it was the key to
your success in life in other words what
advice would you give to your former
self
yeah well first of all i have to say the
thing that really perplexed me and i
don't know that it's really along this
question that picture behind you
still well i'm here by inviting you
to come to san diego i'd be one of my
top
top outstanding graduates we'll get you
a phd
in no time at all uh
and a simpler sense i think um what i
discovered
and it was probably in that time frame
maybe a little later you know what i
like about
um sir arthur's words there is that i
think really
the magic does happen when we get out of
our comfort zone when we start
kind of going beyond that and we learn
a lot about ourselves then you know not
just our strengths but our
weaknesses and have to accept that we
have those um
you know that was a key kind of thing
for me but also that
you've got to get to a point where you
have
enough confidence in yourself
to take
action with respect to the things that
you have total control of
and i'll use an example because i i
really believe by doing that you open up
such wonderful opportunities for
yourself right that you would not have
but you have total control of so
i for years thought the astronaut thing
you know watched
watched neil and buzz walk on the moon
six or seven years old even then you
know that's an extraordinary thing to
see happen
right thought it was really cool i went
through my whole life wanting to know
how things fly how rocket ships fly
um was working as an engineer a nasa
engineer at kennedy space center for
almost 10 years when i finally
discovered that wow you know 99.9
of what an astronaut job is is not
flying in space
sadly you know every astronaut wants it
to be that you know but it's not
and at least 80 of it is a lot like what
i was doing already
but up until that point i had convinced
myself
that astronaut was a job that only other
special people get to do
i had absolutely told myself that
to the point of where i would not on my
own have ever
picked up the pen and filled out the
application
that is the one thing i had total
control over in that totally wacky
process
of how or how do you not get selected to
be an astronaut and i would not have
done that on my own
and so i'm very thankful to mentors that
encouraged me to do nothing more than
pick up the pen
and fill out the application but it made
me realize that wow you have to have
enough confidence in yourself to at
least do those things you have control
of
and it's amazing the kind of of
opportunities that can open up as a
result of that
oh nicole that is such phenomenal advice
thank you so much for being on i will
change my background
to now my new favorite background which
will be
of you blasting off at this place i'll
think about that every time i take off
in my own little plane
and i just want to thank you for being a
hero
and uh and being such such a wonderful
ambassador for planet earth on planet
earth
for children and the mission that you're
undertaking is so important
and i want to just thank you for sharing
your time and your wisdom and i hope we
can meet again someday or meet somebody
for the first time maybe
i do too and uh i want to wish you the
best thank you so much nicole for
joining me thank you
thank you too i really appreciate you
including me it's been a pleasure